hello and welcome to this video where
I will show you how to finance your
studies in the United Kingdom studying in the
United Kingdom can be expensive especially
for a foreign student where the
registration fees can amount to a
few tens of thousands of  euros
but that does not allow to scare since
I did not present some solutions so
that your search for financing goes
without problem the basic solution to
raise enough money to pay
registration fees it will be to
take out a loan from  'a
bank borrowing from a bank is a
bit of shifting the problem since
the money you borrow you will have to
repay it sooner or later and therefore the goal
we are going to see is to try to reduce
this amount as much as possible to reduce
this cost a solution that exists is to
find a sponsor a sponsor
what is it can be a company
that will finance part or
all of your year of work  studies with the
aim of  to be able to hire you behind
then it's a bit special
and perhaps a bit difficult to find a
sponsor so in fact the best
solution is going to be to find
scholarships in my opinion obtaining a scholarship is
going to be a better chance of  reduce
your cost of studies in the United Kingdom you will be
able to find scholarships in your
host university which will have a
large number of varied
selection criteria such as academic merit your
social origins or even a
sports expat you will be able to find
scholarships provided by institutions
whether in the UK or in France
such as the quest for Miss France
island or even what are called trusts
in the UK which will
give money to profiles that
interest them and  so it is very
interesting for you to find out
about all these institutions there will
also be mobility grants which
will be able to be provided by either your
home university or regions
which will encourage  mobility in the
United Kingdom for foreign students
as far as I am concerned I managed to
collect all of my
registration fees a woman of 30,000 euros
through so many different bears which
allowed me to avoid contracting  a
loan so in conclusion the search for
financing it will represent a large
part of your study project in the
United Kingdom but do not be afraid of it
now that all these solutions
have been presented to you